the German election has delivered a
clear if somewhat confusing snapshot of
the changing political landscape of the
country no government as yet the SPD won
the most votes but the very narrow
margin of victory means the CDU could
also be able to form a coalition
government as negotiations begin let's
walk you through the numbers with our
election analyst William glucroft
that's right we have two parties
basically saying they have a right to
form a coalition and be that next
Government after Angel America let's see
just how right they are let's look at
these results on the screen our top
parties we have the SPD Center left
coming out on top at 25.7 percent of the
vote
followed by less than two percentage
points by the cdu-csu conservative block
remember that's Angela mackerel's party
that's been in power for much for almost
the last 16 years keep an eye on these
third and fourth parties these ones in
the middle the greens and that yellow
bar the Liberal fdp Party the free
Democrats these two are most likely
going to be the ones to allow either the
center left or the center right to
actually form that government there's
going to be a lot of horse trading going
on a lot of maneuvering a lot of
negotiating socialists left they're
lucky to even be in the bundestag at all
failing to meet that five percent
threshold that you need to get into the
bundestag but they have enough direct
candidates to have a few seats and the
afd have been ruled out of working with
any other party given their far right
views now this is only a partial picture
let's look at the pluses and minuses who
actually won and lost in comparison to
the 2017 election Well it can't be clear
the cdu-csu conservative block they are
down a historic nine percentage points
they are at an all-time low whereas the
SPD overall also scoring very low but
they're up five percent from their 2017
performance and the greens are having an
all-time high right now almost six
percent natural allies there the center
left and the greens but the center right
is going to be doing a lot to try to woo
the greens and the yellow party there
you see the free Democrats to try to
form a coalition now voting turnout in
Germany is usually very high let's see
if it was as high as it often is here it
is now
77 percent
was the turnout it looks like
not as high as it's been in the last few
election Cycles but also not as low a
very solid 77 percent Germans are not
required to vote but they do like to
turn out and show their ballot and make
their voice heard
so William glue Croft no German voters
now face a prospect of months of
uncertainty as parties enter into
Coalition talks so let's take a closer
look at how we got here
after a tight race the final results
brought Clarity all of Schultz and his
social Democrats edging a small but
definite lead over the conservatives
it's a breathtaking turnaround for a
party that only a few months ago many
had written off
but the SPD won't be able to govern
alone their leader made it clear who his
favorite Partners would be
the boat has made it very clear they
told us that we should form the
government they strengthened three
parties the social Democrats the greens
and the fdp
and that is the obvious mandate by
voters that these three parties should
lead the next government
the social Democrats won't be the only
party trying to win allies
despite leading the conservative party
of outgoing Chancellor Angela Merkel to
their worst ever result the CDU
Chancellor candidate Amin lashed didn't
concede his party's right to govern
no party can derive a mandate to govern
from this result
that also applies to the SPD the
election campaign is now over and no one
can act as though they alone can decide
who will form a government
that's why talks with potential partners
are now necessary
but it looks as though the conservatives
won't be getting first dibs in such
talks with the two smaller parties
in their post-election press conference
the greens co-leaders indicated that it
would be the social Democrats they would
turn to First
there's a certain logic to talking to
the SPD and the FTP now that doesn't
mean that we rule out talking to the
conservatives
the other would be king makers the
business friendly fdp even went as fast
to suggest that they would speak to the
greens before approaching either of the
two main parties
whatever the outcome of the Coalition
talks it looks like the new government
in Berlin will be made up of three
parties an arrangement that is
unprecedented at the national level of
German politics after the last general
election four years ago negotiations
dragged on for over four months
Schultz promised that with him in charge
there would be a speedier resolution my
idea is
that we will be very fast in getting a
result for this government and it should
be before Christmas if possible
till then
hold the fort her time and office
extends until a new Chancellor is ready
to take over
let's talk through the horse trading
with DW Chief political correspondent
Melinda crane welcome Melinda
um
seems like a big promise there Olaf
Schultz saying he can do a deal by
Christmas do you think he can well if we
look at his own personal uh
characteristics he is a very experienced
politician he has been part of Coalition
negotiations before and he's a
pragmatist so all of those would count
in his favor favor in terms of can he do
a deal he does however have a very
divided party and one of the big
questions will be that their party was
unusually United during the election
campaign with the left leaning wing of
the party essentially uh biting their
tongues and biting their time the
question is for how long and whether the
election of nearly 50 a young socialists
young representatives of the Social
Democratic party will try to put on the
pressure and exact a price because that
will make it a lot harder for Olaf
Schultz to make offers to the
market-friendly free Democrats yeah
let's talk about the the the the two
likely a suitors and the the the fdp the
free Democrats and the greens who are
waiting to see what what they could be
offered what do they want what will they
want in order to throw their lot in with
one side or the other and Elena berbach
has made a crystal clear she wants to
see climate change put at the absolute
front and center of the next government
program she's the greens uh Chancellor
candidate absolutely no longer
Chancellor candidate now of course but
uh the party leader together with Robert
habik and they've both said we have to
see uh getting ahead of the climate
crisis as a theme that runs through
everything we do in the next government
from transport to how we organize the
schools and how we organize social
welfare programs and how we begin to
Better Price energy and and end so
that's very clear and they have said so
now the FTP claims that it also wants to
move forward on tackling uh the climate
crisis but they want to do so in a
business friendly way that doesn't
saddle Germany with a lot of debt and
doesn't require the government to raise
taxes in other words they want to keep
costs down which has led the spd's
left-wing leader Kevin kunet as you say
this is voodoo economics it's not going
to work so there you already see the
kind of challenges that these
negotiations if they even become formal
negotiations at this point we're talking
only about exploratory talks but that's
the kind of choices that they will face
the kind of trade-offs that will be at
stake and essentially it's going to very
much come down to a choice between more
state or more Market okay stay with us
Melinda we're going to bring uh uh
election analyst William glue Croft in
he's going to talk us through some of
the shifts in voting patterns
that's right uh there's just so much to
talk about about who voted for whom in
this election let's have a look we were
just talking about greens
CDU where everyone kind of Falls let's
look at the FTP first these liberal
Democrats who voted for them
young people young people voted for the
liberal Democrats the largest portion of
their voters are 18 to 24 year olds
including those first-time voters 18
year olds and it goes down in in in in
order there to older voters it seems
like younger people are really it's
really resonating with them the fdps
kind of calls for digitalization and
more innovation in business and these
kinds of things we heard it already from
the FTP that they are the future that
they are the smaller parties are where
younger people want to go to and we can
see that also with the greens the greens
had a very similar result as well again
the younger voters are coming out to
vote for the smaller parties they're not
thrilled with the bigger parties uh on
either the center right or the center
left you can see also here start going
from youngest to oldest most to least
obviously the greens message of
environment of climate resonating very
strongly with young people as well now
one of the other are big things to talk
about is voter migration who stole votes
from whom this is one of my favorite
things to look at because it shows just
how clear the shifting landscape is here
in Germany just to show you one example
the cdu-csu that center right block has
been in power for almost the last 16
years under Angela Merkel they lost more
than 1.5 million votes to the center
left going from the center right to the
center left they also lost 920 000
voters to the greens
and 490 000 voters to the liberal free
Democrats that is a message to the CDU
CSU that they have some issues with
their voter base and if it weren't for
Germany skewing old which tends to
support the center right that they would
be might be even even bigger trouble
than they are right now
William thank you for that fascinating
figures um Melinda crane is still with
us let's talk about that voter migration
uh Melinda um one and a half million
voters leaving the CDU to going to the
SPD why this is the inevitable end of
the big tent era you could say the
social Democrats and the conservatives
Angela Merkel CDU plus its Bavarian
sister party the CSU they used to be
seen as the people's parties they were
parties that had a 30 40 percent uh each
of the overall vote that era is now
definitively over Angela Merkel had
taken her conservative party toward the
middle of the political Spectrum she had
blurred the boundaries between left and
right and therefore kept the
conservatives uh sort of as a big tent
party perhaps past the natural lifetime
of that kind of a party but it's over
now Armin lash it made it very clear
during the campaign especially when he
designated his so-called team for the
future and it included a party Elder
who's known for his free market ideology
free dish mats that he would be taking
the party back toward the right and
therefore you see this Mass migration of
Voters who perhaps liked Angela merkel's
middle of the road politics who say nope
this is not the party for me anymore and
therefore and also probably objected to
amilashit as Chancellor candidate and
therefore moved to the SPD and then
another big batch of them to the greens
fascinating indeed okay Melinda crane
DWG political correspondent thank you so
much
foreign
possible effects of these changes on
transatlantic relations the Thomas
Kleiner brockhoff is Vice President of
the German martial fund of the United
States welcome to DW even without
knowing its final outcome has this
election and the prospect of a
chancellor who is not Angela Merkel a
change the country's position
internationally
well that's a little early to to tell
because we don't even know what the
Coalition will look like but there are
some constant of course in the in the
German geography of the political
landscape uh all four parties that could
potentially form the Coalition that
includes the two uh bigger ones the
Christian democrats and social Democrats
support the basic
underlying structure of German foreign
policy with strong transatlantic
relations with a European devotion with
a commitment to more European
integration I I don't think any of this
is going away with this with this
election but there are a number of
smaller to medium-sized changes that we
might be might be seeing especially on
China policy depending on what type of
Coalition it is on defense spending and
NATO
so there are changes but there are not
architect actual changes yeah let's talk
let's pick up one of those points that
defense spending we know that NATO has
long been a Cornerstone of German
political policy we also know I'm going
to put no in in quotation marks that the
greens are likely to be part of the next
uh German government and they're not so
keen on on uh increased military
spending towards NATO so what changes
are we likely to see there
um the the the next Coalition as you say
will include the uh the greens we know
that they have been interestingly
pre-hawkish when it comes to uh China
relations and Russia relations based on
their uh on human rights policy but they
are
hesitant to back up these claims with
hard power now they've done a pretty
interesting trick in preparation for for
this election within their within their
party they've rejected the two percent
goal uh claiming it will uh increase the
the percentage when the economy goes
down as a as a nonsensical goal
but it doesn't mean that they're not
willing to increase the defense budget
you will have shown us the likely
Chancellor if it if it comes to that
um
it has has said multiple times during
the campaign that he stands by doing
what he has done during his time as
Finance Minister uh moderately
increasing uh the defense budget so that
will not please the Americans because
we're not getting too close to two
percent uh in uh in a couple of years
but the trajectory I think will remain
the same and Eve the greens will not
will not change that that trajectory
upward in defense spending the Super
Center that you're talking about of
course being the two percent of GDP that
has been set as a sort of bar for uh
NATO entry where from it from its
members
um China you you mentioned there as a
potential a point of uh of friction dude
where do you see that happening how do
you see that playing out
well
first of all I think Xi Jinping is is is
sure is changing the perception of China
in this country and he is thus uh
playing a part in uh in changing uh
slowly changing I would have to say a
China policy the assertiveness wolf
Warrior diplomacy the whole uh the whole
behavior during covet the ambition uh
that uh reaching into Europe all of this
uh reaches the German population makes
it a a an easy so Xi Jinping is the
first player here the second player is
Angela Merkel she is now it will be in a
couple of months going off the scene and
she sort of was on holdout of an of an
old China policy of a of a policy that's
still built on on on on on relative to a
relative openness to towards China China
trade and trying not to get in into a
thick of a confrontational attitude
towards China she has been pushing back
against all those who tried to take a
more distant even a more hawkish
approach on China she's gone and that
will change the policy and thirdly the
third element that will change that is
Joe Biden an American positioning here
Germany will would feel uneasy being
left behind in the Convoy of Western
Nations it won't probably be out front
in terms of hawkishness Visa via China
but he also doesn't want to be left
behind so I could see subtle changes or
or a a a little bit of a step dance in
China policy going forward thank you so
much for that it's very clear Thomas
Kleiner brockhoff of the German martial
fund of the United States
thank you
well there's a lot to take away from
this election in terms of what it
reveals about the changing uh political
landscape within Germany but what comes
next we'll also determine the country's
role as a leading power in the European
Union
so let's bring in D.W Brussels uh bureau
chief Alexandra afan Norman
welcome Alexandra what are the
preferences as far as Brussels is
concerned the chancellor Schultz or a
chantilla lashette
well I think that Brussels could work
with both of them because both
politicians are die-hard Europeans as
merkel's Vice Chancellor and Finance
Minister Olaf Schultz is of course well
known here he's also known as someone
who is in favor of more European
sovereignty when it comes to Industrial
policy defense and climate protection
but Ahmed lushant is also someone who
says that
Germany needs a strong a stronger Europe
he is a promoter of the franco-german
friendship and he served as a member of
the European Parliament so he is also
well known here and I think that the
main takeaway from that German election
is for Brussels that all the parties
that could end up in a government are a
deeply pro-european what is not so good
for Brussels is that it seems that
Coalition talks will take a while and
this is not good news for Brussels
because of course as long as Germany
doesn't have a government little will
move forward in the European Union right
so so what are the main tasks that
Germany's Next Chancellor will have to
face in terms of European politics
well I think that very high on the
agenda is fighting climate change the
European commission has introduced a
quite ambitious climate package and now
it is up for member states to agree on
that and of course Germany is here
needed to search for possible
compromises and another very important
issue on the agenda is is the post-covet
economic recovery and the question
whether the quite strict fiscal rules
that are now suspended because of the
pandemic should be relaxed in the future
and here you can see that differences
between parties do matter because I
think we can assume that social
Democrats and the greens they would
support that while the merkel's
conservatives and the free Democrats are
very skeptical okay thank you for that
Brussels bureau chief Alexander fondrana
and what about Russia I asked DW's
Moscow bureau chief Yuri rashetto what
path German Russian relations are likely
to take now
well uh Phil at least that's what is the
Kremlin hopes for kremlin's spokesperson
dimitriskov stressed that Moscow seeks
continuity but when it comes to German
Russian relations he admitted that the
two countries will still have their
differences but said he hoped that
Russia into Germany would be United in
the belief that problems can and should
be resolved through dialogue actually
the main election result for the Kremlin
is that Germany won't have a Chancellor
from the green party that was a bit of a
fear here that the Kremlin had
especially because Germany and Russia
have such close economic ties the greens
are the only major political force in
Germany that demands not only that
sanctions against Russia continue but in
particular that the north stream two gas
projects for example should be stopped
and the pipeline is a very important
issue for Moscow also uh it's not yet
clear what Coalition will be in the
German government a green politician
could still become foreign minister and
that could be tough for the Russians as
the Green since declared human rights to
be the most important issue in the
German Russian agenda but at the same
time the influence of the greens on
Germany's new foreign policy will most
likely be limited especially because all
the other members of a possible
coalition government the Christian
democrats the social Democrats and the
free Democrats in general rely on a
dialogue with Russia none of these
parties want a radical break with the
Kremlin right so what challenges are
merkel's successors likely to have in
dealing with Russia
well I think ideally he should speak
speak Russian like Angela Merkel did to
be the next so-called Putin fishtail
which translates from German as a Putin
understand I'm joking of course I think
that Russian German relations are so
close and so diverse that merkel's
personal relationship with Putin wasn't
the only decisive Factor Germany is too
important for Russia and President Putin
will continue to try to work closely
with with whoever becomes Chancellor but
when it comes to challenges Vladimir
Putin's foreign policy actually has some
basic principles that are quite easy to
understand even for people who don't
belong to the category for Puti of Putin
faster on the one hand Putin stands for
taking a tough stance against the West
to assert Russia's importance in the
Bold stage on The Bold stage and that's
something the new chancellor has to be
keep in mind on the other hand Putin
needs Germany's important member state
within the EU as a country which has
very close economic ties with Russia and
Russia remains an important part of a
Germany not only economically but for
example on the subject of security as
well Moscow has close contacts with
Central Asia with the former Soviet
republics which in turn have a long
border with Afghanistan and because of
its influence on Afghanistan Russia can
also be very useful for the German
government okay DW bureau chief Yuri
rashetto in Moscow thank you so much